everyone this is one of those days when
I can't give a full new episode of your
daily equation I'll pick it up tomorrow
with a live session so please join me
for that but for today I thought I'd
just quickly draw your attention to some
interesting news that's been bubbling up
of late having to do with the strange
little wispy particles called neutrinos
you perhaps read about some of the
intriguing not fully conclusive as yet
but some intriguing results coming out
of Japan which have found evidence for
an asymmetry between neutrinos and their
anti particle partners anti neutrinos
and and why is this so important well a
big question that we've been struggling
with for a very long time is this since
it's the case that when matter and
antimatter come together they annihilate
they destroy each other say into a burst
of energy a burst of photons let's say
why is it that there's any matter left
over today given our understanding that
in the early universe near at the
beginning there seems to be no
distinction between matter and
antimatter except you know one has a
positive charge one has a negative of
its charge vice-versa
so they stand in that relationship but
the particles otherwise are treated we
think by the fundamental equations in a
symmetric manner which means you would
think that in the early universe when
particles were first being created
there'd been equal amount of matter and
antimatter which means over time the
matter and antimatter would find each
other an eye light and there'd be
nothing left over so the big question
it's a version of course of live and
it's this question why is there
something rather than nothing but this
is not sort of the philosophical version
of that question it's the really brass
tacks physics version of that question
if matter and antimatter were created in
equal quantities which seems quite
reasonable
based upon our understanding of the
fundamental processes and if when matter
and antimatter come together they
violate why is there any matter left
over at all and one of the potential
solutions that people have kicked around
now for decades is maybe there is a
subtle difference between matter and
antimatter and maybe that subtle
difference is what's responsible for
creating a tiny imbalance in the amount
of matter versus the amount of
antimatter and maybe that tiny imbalance
is the origin of the leftover matter
that allows the universe as we currently
observe it to exist in fact you can do a
calculation it's kind of a fun
calculation and maybe you can even take
this as your daily equation your
equation for today what would that
equation be that equation would be the
simple equation a billion and one - a
billion equals one all right kind of
silly sounding equation but it has
potentially deep physical significance
in the following interpretation so what
you would need the calculations showed
that what you would need is for every
billion particles of antimatter you need
a billion and one particles of matter so
that when they annihilate it there'd be
one particle of matter left over for
each billion particles of matter say
that you began with that's the size of
the disparity the size of the imbalance
that you need between matter and
antimatter so that when they annihilate
there will be enough left over enough
matter left over to create you know
stars galaxies planets people all that
good stuff that constitutes the universe
as we know it
so the question is what could be the
origin of that billion two billion and
one disparity what could be driving it
and one possibility is to look at these
particles called neutrinos and the
suggestion has been that perhaps the
asymmetry is built into the way
neutrinos verse
they're antineutrino cousins how they
behave and so there has been a lot of
work on this but the one experiment in
particular that has been recently in the
news this t2k experiment - chi - Kamioka
experiment it's an experiment in Japan
where neutrinos are fired through a
large span of bedrock neutrinos can go
through like trillions of miles of lead
with only a small possibility of
interacting with the particles of that
led they just sort of pass right through
these wispy ghost-like particles so you
can fire these particles you know
through long distances and you can
measure how they change along the
journey and there's some evidence that
the way neutrinos and antineutrinos
change along that journey the way they
so called oscillate
there are various flavors of neutrinos
and flavors of anti neutrinos and it
turns out that these particles can
oscillate between one flavor and another
electron neutrinos muon neutrinos tau
neutrinos and the way they oscillate
between these distinct flavors there's a
little bit of evidence maybe that's not
a good description there's some evidence
now and and and that evidence is is
quite compelling that neutrinos and
antineutrinos
do not oscillate between their potential
flavors in exactly the same way at
exactly the same rate and it could be
that that slight disparity in the way
neutrinos versus anti neutrinos
oscillate that in principle may give
rise to the billion versus billion and
one disparity in antimatter versus
matter which may itself be the reason
why there's any stuff any material stuff
left over in the universe so it's an
exciting development we would not yet
say that it has risen to the level of a
true discovery but the nature of the
data is making this story quite
compelling and quite worthy of attention
and I like to just leave off this little
brief version of your daily equation by
drawing your attention to a program that
we had not too long ago at the World
Science Festival I'm gonna link it right
down there called the matter of
antimatter and it had some of the
world's great leaders in this journey to
try to understand where the
matter/antimatter
asymmetry has come from and indeed some
of the folks who are focusing their
attention on neutrinos were in this
program so I think you'll enjoy it I
moderated it try to keep the
conversation moving along there are some
equations in this program some of you
have asked to see the Dirac equation you
will see the Dirac equation in this
program if you check it out so do take a
look at that program I think you'll
enjoy it and we'll pick up our next
version of your daily equation with a
live session on Friday tomorrow until
then take care